Uh, let's go next to our caller from the three,
two, three area code.
Who's calling today from three to three?
Yeah, this is Bard.
Hey, mark, what's going on?
Well, yeah, I was just wondering, were you
one of those people that, um, push the narrative
that the Russian had impacted our elections?
Uh, I mean I, I saw some interesting reports
suggesting that it's possible because of how
close it was in certain states that their
social media interference could at least hypothetically
mathematically have been the difference maker.
But it's not, you know, in some ways when
you have a thousand factors that impact that
outcome, it's hard to say.
This one thing was definitely the difference
maker.
Well, how did they want to buy the number
of people who, who they claim were affected?
Yeah.
Well that's exactly, that's exactly the difficulty,
right?
I mean it's like, okay, so you look at Wisconsin,
Hillary Clinton didn't go to Wisconsin towards
the end.
How many votes went to Trump over Hillary
because of that.
Then you have to contrast that with how many
people were targeted in with Wisconsin by
foreign dollars in social media campaigns
and then what percentage of them voted differently
or didn't vote as are, I mean you're getting
to exactly the point which is there are a
thousand different things.
James Comi coming out and talking about the
Hillary Clinton investigation.
What impact did that have on voting in Wisconsin?
So it's very difficult to say with any certitude.
This one thing is what decided, but we can
still talk about the number of factors that
played a role, if that makes sense.
Oh yes.
But here's the thing, did this Russian campaign,
was it meant to influence Hillary voters to
vote for Trump?
Maybe.
I don't know specifically what campaigns they
ran in any particular state.
I, I'm they, they are more sophisticated than
just saying, let's get Hillary voters to vote
for Trump.
They, you know, one of the strategies that
they used was to foment racial anxiety around
police shootings in places like Ferguson and
Baltimore.
It's, it's more nuance than let's find Hillary
voters and feed them disinformation to get
them to vote.
Trump.
It's not that, I think that might be too simplistic
of an understanding of what these camps, how
these campaigns work.
Yeah.
Because my, you know, my belief is like, I'm
of the firm belief that most people on the
left are more intelligent than the people
on the right.
Hmm.
How did, what, why do you believe that?
Um, what do, because there's a lot of uneducated
low income people who vote Republican, right?
I mean
sure.
But there's also people who are low income
who vote for Democrats too.
I mean, I, yeah, if he, I'm not saying I agree
or disagree.
Agree with you.
I'm saying how do you justify, that's a pretty
bold assertion to say generally the left is
smarter than the right.
Well, just basically on, on certain statistics
that I've seen that most of the, uh, most
college educated people are, are liberal on
the left.
So the, it's a little bit different.
So the more education you have, the more likely
you are to be more left than right.
That is true.
Yes.
What look, okay, so based on that, right,
I'm a firm believer that yeah, the people
on the left are intelligent.
There.
There are a lot of college educated, intelligent
people.
And I'm just wondering, um, how intelligent
college educated people, what have been fooled
into believing obvious lies.
Cause see, I'm a bit firm that this whole
idea of Russian influence, it never happened
because I wasn't influenced by, by Russians.
I, you know, I didn't vote for Hillary.
Not because of any.
Okay.
Yeah, but now you're, hello.
Hello.
Oh, you just got out.
You're cutting in and out.
Yeah.
Listen, W you, you are one out of 120 million
voters.
So the fact that you were or weren't influenced
by any particular thing doesn't, doesn't really
tell us that much one way or the other.
But mark, you're thinking about these things
the right way.
I'm going to let you go cause you're breaking
a breaking up and I do, it's been months since
we heard from him months and months and months.
Um, let's go.
Oh nope.
We just lost him.
We just had someone I wanted to go to that
we had not heard from for months who I wanted
to talk to you.
Okay, well on that note, I am over time already.
So that does it for today.
Sorry to everybody that I was not able to
get to on the phones today.
We will take calls again.
I will be livestreaming, uh, in the next week
and that is another option,
community to call in as the phones often do.
Open.
We'll take a quick break and be back with
more right after this